[Music]
a fund continues to grow tonight to help
a woman who was evicted eight news now
viewers reaching out after seeing her
story first shared by the i-team vanessa
murphy is live near charleston and
mohave with an update for us vanessa
and brian viewers have called emailed
posted on social media to ask how they
can help corrine continue after she was
evicted from her home here with her pets
you can see the lock is still here
get downtown
corrine continue and her pets are
homeless she says she's staying on a
friend's couch while her pets are in a
yard with no shade in the heat this has
been so heartbreaking and so
nerve-wracking i can't begin to tell you
the i-team shared contino's story last
week she told us she lost her business
due to the covid 19 pandemic with no
income and months of unpaid rent she was
evicted i slept in my car with my
animals the first first night
viewers reached out to eight news now as
of monday afternoon donations totaled
more than 3 400 dollars in this gofundme
account i want to say thank you to
everybody out there her landlord tells
the i-team he'll let continue move back
into the house if she pays back rent of
8 800 dollars continues hoping to do
that if she can raise the money she
tells us the rent is less than 700
dollars that's far below the average in
the las vegas area of more than 1200 for
an apartment i'll never find a place
with a yard before i can have my dogs
and shade and
i was very comfortable there continue
and her landlord were both counting on
chap the cares housing assistance
program by law in nevada a tenant should
not be evicted if they're waiting for
their application to be processed
records show cantino may not have
mentioned the application during a
hearing and the eviction was ordered now
that cantino's been evicted according to
clark county those housing dollars won't
come through this pandemic has destroyed
my life evictions are expected to
continue to increase as more tenants
struggle to pay bills this wasn't
supposed to happen
we have links and resources for both
tenants and landlords at
eightnewsnow.com as well as that
gofundme link now some viewers did reach
out asking if they could help karine
continue by possibly fostering her pets
i asked her about that today she said
she'd think about it sounds like she
does not want to be separated from them
though reporting live vanessa murphy 8
news now